[tense music]
CHRISTIAN: You'll never get the
truth from a current extremist.
Their whole job is to
lie to you and to spin
things their own way.
Which is why I say,
if you want the truth,
talk to a former extremist.
JOURNALIST: You still
have the jacket?
CHRISTIAN: I still
have the jacket.
JOURNALIST: Oh.
CHRISTIAN: So this
was CASH, Chicago
Area Skinheads, which was that
first American neo-Nazi group.
And then on the back--
JOURNALIST: Final Solution, wow.
Final Solution
was my band name
with the 88, which
is kind of shorthand
for the eighth letter
of the alphabet, HH,
which stands for "Heil Hitler."
What was the final solution?
CHRISTIAN: Well, the
final solution in my mind
was the same thing that
was in Hitler's mind,
and that was the
extermination of the Jews.
That was the ultimate solution.
JOURNALIST (VOICEOVER):
From the age of 14 to 22,
Christian Vittrilini
helped build
America's first neo-Nazi
skinhead organization.
But today, he has
devoted his life
to helping people disengage
from the same extremist
groups he used to belong to.
CHRISTIAN: What I see when
I look at those pictures
is not a tough guy.
I see a very insecure,
low self-esteem,
and broken young man.
And I think it's
important for people
to understand that what draws
people to those movements,
hate movements, is not
the ideology initially.
Nobody is born to hate.
It's something that we learn.
And for me, I was
searching for an identity,
a community, and a purpose.
JOURNALIST
(VOICEOVER): Christian
was ripe for radicalization.
And on a street
corner in 1987, he
was approached by
a skinhead leader
and recruited on the spot.
CHRISTIAN: That man
told me that I mattered.
Nobody had ever
told me that before.
And I bought into the ideas
that they put in my head
because it made
me feel powerful.
INTERVIEWER: With me today,
Chris Vittrilini, 19-years-old,
director of the Illinois
chapter of the Northern
Hammer Skinheads.
Well, I believe
we're warriors today
and we're fighting for a great
cause, which is the white race.
CHRISTIAN: I noticed my
life change immediately.
I went from somebody
who had been bullied
to now somebody who was feared.
JOURNALIST
(VOICEOVER): Christian
describes his
radicalization as a descent
into a community of
like-minded individuals.
They consumed a potent mix of
race-based conspiracy theories
and misinformation
that fueled their anger
and justified their attacks.
I wonder how that radicalization
process compares to today.
(SINGING) Damn [inaudible]
just call me a shrink.
CHRISTIAN: In my day, it
was very face to face.
But what's happened
now is the internet
has kind of become that
digital alley that I was
recruited in, except
it's an all you can eat,
24 hour, hate buffet.
And there are millions and
millions of young people
like I was at 14-years-old.
What about the
El Paso shooter?
CHRISTIAN: The whole idea of
a lone wolf is a misnomer.
While there are white
supremacists who
may never in real life meet
another white supremacist,
that doesn't mean
they're not connected.
JOURNALIST (VOICEOVER):
The internet
is a technological game changer,
amplifying lies and weaponizing
propaganda like never before.
Extremists are flooding social
media and encrypted chat
forums, creating an alternate
universe of imaginary threats
where lies become truth and
conspiracy becomes reality.
As of May 2021, Facebook
banned 250 groups
linked to white supremacy.
Often what starts as edgy
memes that target young men
on platforms like Reddit,
Twitter, and others, quickly
spirals into more
extreme content.
The El Paso shooter,
for example,
wrote that he was inspired
by a manifesto posted online
by a shooter in New
Zealand who livestreamed
himself murdering 51 Muslims.
Called "The Great Replacement,"
this manifesto justified
the killings as a
defense of white culture
from the existential
threat posed by Muslims,
minorities, and immigrants.
The fact that these
white genocide fears have
been debunked time and
again over centuries
means little online.
Within the echo chamber
of the movement,
the New Zealand shooter's
manifesto is revered and used
to indoctrinate new recruits.
All too often,
that's how it works.
The speed of online
radicalisation
helps explain why race-based
attacks are on the rise.
As Christian said, nobody is
born to hate, it's learned.
[upbeat music]